hi it's Nick Gillespie for recent TV we
are at the Democratic National
Convention in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
we're gonna ask people to compare
statements from the top three polling
candidates and see who they actually
like most these are statements by the
top three polling presidential
candidates warm we're gonna bomb the
[ __ ] out of them it's time for the
United States to start thinking of Iraq
as a business opportunity or let's stop
dropping bombs let's stop with the
military interventions the last one this
sounds like a trick question but I would
have to go with the third option because
I believe that war is never the correct
option number two the second one - okay
number three which comes closest to
expressing your views the last one okay
now we're talking about Internet the
internet and freedom of speech we've got
a shut off terrorists means of
communicating online we have to talk to
them about closing that Internet up and
then the third is there's nothing wrong
with the internet that I want the
government to fix the second one second
okay absolutely nothing wrong with the
Internet none of the above
one pot legalization that should be a
state issue but it's a bad idea second
statement I want to wait and see what
the evidence is from state experiments
or I became the highest-ranking elected
official in the US to advocate the
legalization of marijuana - works for an
individual state that should be a
state-by-state issue I think number two
represents me
the third option because we already know
that decriminalization work the one by
the states to see okay you want to wait
and see yeah okay immigration
I voted numerous times to spend money to
build a barrier to try to prevent
illegal immigrants from coming in the
second statement is we have at least 11
million people that came in illegally
they will go out or immigration into the
United States by ambitious willing
workers and their families is a good
thing three absolutely the third I
remind you that the Republicans are the
ones responsible for bringing these
so-called the illegals into the country
so the final issue is trade the TPP is a
horrible deal it is a deal that is going
to lead to nothing but trouble second
statement is I hoped it would be the
gold standard in looking at it it didn't
meet my standards and the third is the
trans-pacific partnership would in fact
advance free trade and so I would
support that document get rid of TPP get
rid of NAFTA get rid of all of it I'm
almost an ene on that but I will go with
to the middle 1/3 those all blended
together but no TPP does any of that the
fact that you lined up with the
libertarian at all does that make you
rethink your politics or rethink
libertarianism it makes me think about
it but I know that the Libertarian Party
but would have to build status of both
the other parties a little surprise but
there again the topics are so ambiguous
it's almost it's one of those things
that you really don't
to have to vote on but you know you're
gonna have to so what I would do is get
my research and look at what my leaders
are doing and then I would probably come
form to that does your response to any
of these make you rethink your politics
at all or rethink your allegiances I
believe that what politicians can say in
sound bites doesn't reflect their policy
priorities and that we need to fight for
economic and racial justice and that I
don't believe that Gary Johnson or
Hillary Clinton side with social justice
on all of the right issues does this
make you rethink your Hillary not at all
so far you're three for three on
as a libertarian not a Democrat I want
you to know that I think you better go
talk to Gary Johnson and he might be
with the wrong party huh